bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du jeu de la vie alors non je ne fais
pas référence à un jeu de société ou à
une variante de la roulette russe
mais un drôle de petit programme
informatique imaginé dans les années 70
par le mathématicien john conway depuis
presque cinquante ans ce jeu fascine les
mathématiciens et les informaticiens
mais aussi les biologistes et les
philosophes parce qu'il nous montre
comment un système évoluant selon des
règles simplistes peut engendrer des
résultats incroyablement riche et d'une
certaine manière il nous aide à mieux
comprendre comment un gros tas date au
moins d'interactions peut se retrouver à
former les êtres complexes et pensant
que nous sommes
[Musique]
le jeu de la vie se joue sur un tableau
de cases carrées et qu'on peut prendre
aussi grand qu'on veut et on imagine que
chacune de ces cases peut héberger une
cellule comme une cellule vivante
si la case en contient une on l'a
coloris en noir et à l'invers si elle
est vide on la laisse en blanc
voici par exemple une configuration
possible très simple dans laquelle on a
seulement 6 cellules vivantes
maintenant l'idée du jeu de la vie c'est
de faire évoluer une population de
cellules au tour par tour
selon des règles qui sont fixés à
l'avancé et qui sont enfantines
règle numéro 1 une cellule ne survivra
au tour suivant que si elle est entourée
par deux ou trois voisines
si vous voulez en dessous de deux
voisines la cellule meurt d'isolement et
au-dessus de 3 elmer de surpopulation et
règle numéro 2 si une case vide est
entouré par exactement trois voisines
elle devient vivante au tour suivant une
cellule n'est à cet endroit là pour voir
ce que ça donne essayons d'appliquer ces
deux règles d'évolution sur notre
exemple précédent
ici on a une cellule qui n'a qu'une
voisine
donc il va mourir d'isolement ici on a
une case vide qui a exactement trois
voisines
donc va y avoir une naissance ici et
pareil pour la et pour les trois cas ce
qu'on trouve en dessous au tour suivant
on a donc une nouvelle situation qui est
celle ci est ensuite on n'a plus qu'à
recommencer pour re faire évoluer cette
nouvelle configuration
on va avoir plusieurs morts par
surpopulation et aussi quelques
naissances et ainsi de suite
on peut recommencer autant qu'on veut
vous voyez qu'appliquer les deux règles
est extrêmement simple et en fait on
appelle ça le jeu de la vie mais c'est
pas vraiment un jeu puisqu'il ya pas de
joueur vous n'avez aucune décision à
prendre à part choisir la situation de
départ et ensuite il suffit d'appliquer
les règles pas à pas sans réfléchir
si on vient notre petit exemple on a
atteint la configuration suivante un
carré fait de 4 cellules
et là vous pouvez vous convaincre que
plus rien ne se passe ni mort ni
naissance la figure n'évolue plus elle
est stable évidemment le fait qu'on
arrive sur cette structure stable est
lié au choix qu'on a fait pour la
configuration de départ si on avait pris
une configuration différente
les choses se seraient passées autrement
pour explorer différents scénarios on va
pas continuer à faire ça à la main il se
trouve que les règles sont extrêmement
simples donc très facile à programmer et
ça va permettre de calculer beaucoup
plus vite les évolutions alors il existe
plein de petites applications qu'on peut
télécharger mais pour pouvoir vous faire
des belles illustrations gerco des mois
même le jeu de la vie en python et pour
ceux que ça intéresse mettrait le lien
dans la description qu'en john conway a
proposé les règles du jeu
vie en 1970 lui et quelques acolytes ont
commencé à explorer plein de
configuration de départ pour voir où ça
les mener bon évidemment si je parle
d'une seule cellule ou même de 2 elle
meurt tout de suite d'isolement donc
prenons donc trois cellules en ligne et
voilà ce qui se passe quand on les fait
évoluer on n'obtient pas une
configuration stable comme tout à
l'heure mais une structure aussi lente
on l'appelle le clignotant en partant de
4 cellules en ligne l'évolution s'arrête
mais sur une nouvelle structure stable
qu'on surnomme la ruche et avec cinq
cellules en ligne on obtient au bout de
quelques tours une nouvelle structure
oscillante constitué de quatre
clignotant mais en fait on n'obtient pas
toujours des structures stables aussi
lantin parfois certaines structures
finissent par mourir complètement comme
celle ci par exemple
alors je vais pas vous faire toutes les
configurations de départ possibles et
imaginables
ce qui est marrant pour trouver de
nouvelles structures stables ou
oscillante c'est de partir d'une
situation de départ un peu aléatoire de
lancer l'évolution et de boire où ça
nous mène dans les structures stables
qu'on peut trouver comme ça voici par
exemple celle qu'on appelle le bateau le
pain et la mare
et dans les structures oscillante bas
par le clignotant voici la balise et le
crapaud
ce qui est fascinant dans le jeu de la
vie c'est la manière dont des petites
choses simples peuvent engendrer une
grande complexité
par exemple prenez comme situation de
départ la configuration en ruche qui est
stable on l'a dit mais en ajoutant juste
une petite cellule dans un coin lancé
l'évolution et voici ce qui se passe
vous avez maintenant quatre ruches qui
sont apparues
si je prends un escalier comme ça avec
juste 6 cellules va regarder la
structure se développe on se demande
jusqu'où ça va continuer et elle finit
par s'arrêter vers une structure stable
constitué de quatre blocs assez éloignés
les uns des autres et il a fallu
soixante trois générations pour sa part
je pourrais vous en montrer plein comme
ça mais l'observation qui a fasciné
conway et qui lui a montré tout le
potentiel de son petit jeu c'est
l'évolution de cette simple structure
cinq cellules c'est tout et pourtant
regardez
et là en fait je vais devoir accélérer
le film est aussi un peu des zooms et
parce que ça continue encore encore
et voilà la première chose étonnante
c'est qu'il a fallu 1103 générations
pour que l'évolution se stabilise ce qui
est quand même énorme vu qu'on est parti
de cinq cellules tout bête et
l'évolution a été complètement
chaotiques apparemment aucun motif
récurrent et à la fin on se retrouve
avec une configuration sans aucune
symétrie constitué de quatre clignotants
ici et 2,15 structure stable
huit blocs de quatre 4 ruches un bateau
un pain et un navire mais ça n'est pas
ça le plus fascinant au milieu de la
simulation il s'est passé un truc
vraiment étonnant je sais pas si vous
l'avez remarqué je vous le remet
regardez là autour de la 70e génération
ce truc c'est ce qu'on appelle un
planeur sommes regardés y en ad'autres
ici le planeur c'est une structure qui
change de forme mais tous les quatre
tours retrouve sa configuration en
s'étant déplacé d'une case en diagonale
on peut en voir d'autres un peu plus
tard dans la simulation et du coup c'est
une structure qui avance la présence de
ce petit planner est assez
révolutionnaire parce qu'elle montre
deux choses la première c'est qu'un
motif peut avoir une croissance qui sera
infini dans l'espace au cours de
l'évolution il ya huit planeur qui sont
émis et qui vont donc continuer jusqu'à
l'infini
la deuxième chose c'est que ces planeur
père
être de commencer à imaginer une forme
de communication entre des structures et
on va voir que ça ouvre plein de portes
[Musique]
depuis que le jeu de la vie a été
imaginé par conway ses adeptes cherche à
découvrir ou à construire des structures
intéressantes de plus en plus grande et
de plus en plus riches
trouver des grandes structures stables
qui ne soit pas juste des associations
de structures existantes ce n'est pas si
simple
la plus grosse à ce jour c'est la
suivante on l'appelle tout
elle est constituée de 45 cellule du
côté des oscillateurs n'a trouvé plein
d'autres et notamment certains dont la
période d'oscillations n'est pas deux
comme le clignotant mais peut être un
nombre plus élevé par exemple voici une
structure appelée le pulsar qui oscille
avec une période de 3 c'est à dire que
la figure se répète tous les trois tours
autre exemple plus compliqué prenait 10
cellules en ligne
au début on a l'impression que la
structure évolue sans motif particulier
mais en fait elle se répète tous les 15
tours c'est un oscillateur de période 15
qu'on appelle le peinte à décathlon
on connaît maintenant des oscillateurs
de tout un tas de période en voici un
des plus gros c'est un oscillateur deux
périodes 177 pour la configuration se
répète donc tous les 177 tours
du côté des planeurs on a pu aussi
trouver d'autres structures capables de
se déplacer et par exemple les trois
suivants qu'on appelle les vaisseaux
spatiaux respectivement le petit le
moyen et le gros est aussi des très
jolies structure comme celle ci ces lois
du canada bien des plus symétrique comme
celle là qui s'appelle 60 p 5
h20 or tout ça est bien gentil on peut
s'imaginer même poussé le bouchon encore
plus loin
mais la structure qui a provoqué une
petite révolution dans le jeu de la vie
c'est celle ci on l'appelle le canon à
planeur et vous voyez pourquoi c'est une
structure qui oscille tout en produisant
des planeurs
elle a été découverte par bill gross
peur et porte d'ailleurs son nom - le
canon un planeur de gloucester et cette
structure résout une question que conway
s'était posée dès le départ elle montre
que le nombre de cellules vivantes peut
tendre vers l'infini avec le temps bah
oui on ad planner qui sont émis avec un
rythme régulier et qu'ils ne
disparaissent jamais et on peut
évidemment joué à essayer de construire
des canons pour d'autres types de
structures qui se déplace allez voici un
exemple extrême vous souvenez du
vaisseau 60 p 5 h 2 0 eh bien on peut en
fabriquer un canon il est juste
légèrement plus gros que le canon un
planeur en fait oui il est vraiment
vraiment plus gros regardez moi ce
ballet harmonieux vous trouvez pas ça
magnifique en fait qui est magnifique
c'est surtout que toute cette complexité
fascinante découle de seulement deux
règles totalement élémentaire
vous voulez encore d'autres structures
voici ce qu'on appelle un fumeur c'est à
dire une structure qui se déplacent
comme un vaisseau mais en produisant des
débris qui restent derrière elle et en
partant de ce même fumeur mais en
rajoutant dans son sillage des vaisseaux
spatiaux qui vont suivre
on peut en faire une version dite
écologique regardez les vaisseaux vont
convertir les débris du fumeur pour en
faire des planeurs voici une autre
structure de fumeurs assez
impressionnante qu'on appelle un fumeur
en ligne à lui laisse un sacré bordel
derrière lui tout à l'heure on a vu que
le canon un planeur était une structure
assez compact qui permettait de produire
des cellules à l'infini mais en fait on
peut faire encore plus simple que ça
voici une structure de seulement dix
cellules au départ qui paye pas de mine
mais voyons son évolution
regardez au bout d'un moment on remarque
une sorte de routes pavées de blocs se
construit comme ça indéfiniment
avec seulement dix cellules au départ on
peut montrer que c'est la plus petite
structure possible ayant une croissance
infinie
on peut aussi s'amuser à chercher des
structures en croissance infinie qui
soient les plus rapides possibles et là
le record est détenu par cette structure
qu'on appelle max et vous voyez pourquoi
un quand elle évolue bas elle remplit
l'espace d'un motif en rayures de zèbres
qui est localement stable alors stable
mais pas très robuste un regarder ce qui
se passe si j'ajoute artificiellement
une petite perturbation quand on arrive
au bord et ben c'est l'apocalypse mais
la structure la plus spectaculaire pour
moi c'est celle ci elle s'appelle bris
de roanne
elle est constituée de neuf gros
vaisseaux qui laisse des débris et
éjecte des planeurs mais regardez ce
qu'elle produit
les planeurs et les débris finissent par
ce assemblée pour former des canons à
planeur qui se disposent en ligne dans
son sillage et donc plus le temps passe
plus le nombre de planeur et me
simultanément augmente c'est beau non
bon ça fait quelques minutes qu'on fait
des jolis dessins on peut quand même se
demander à quoi tout ça sert alors si
tout ça vous laisse de marbre un
souvenez vous que ce qui fait la beauté
de la chose c'est que toute cette
complexité est engendré à partir de
seulement deux règles extrêmement simple
sur la survie et la naissance des
cellules et c'est ça qui fait tout
l'intérêt du jeu de la vie le fait que
des règles de base élémentaire puisse
donner naissance à des structures et à
des comportements extrêmement complexe
et d'ailleurs personne n'aurait pu
anticiper ray encore
car dans les deux règles qu'elle
pourrait donner naissance à tout ça et
c'est ce phénomène qu'on appelle
l'émergence le fait que des structures
complexes puisse posséder des propriétés
macroscopique qu'on ne retrouve pas dans
leurs constituants de base
on retrouve ces situations d'émergence
aussi bien en physique en biologie mais
aussi en sociologie ou en économie quand
on étudie le comportement des groupes et
c'est parce qu'il nous renseigne sur ces
phénomènes d'émergence qu'on s'intéresse
beaucoup à l'étude de systèmes simples
facilement simule abl informatiquement
comme le jeu de la vie d'ailleurs pour
ceux qui s'en souviennent j'avais déjà
évoqué ces questions dans une vidéo
précédente qui parlait de la fourmi de
langton dans le cas du jeu de la vie on
a pu pousser l'investigation assez loin
par exemple on a pu montrer qu'il
existait des structures capables de
s'auto répliqué comme ce qui se passe
avec les cellules vivantes et d'un point
de vue théorique il a surtout été montré
qu'on pouvait réaliser une machine de
turing avec le jeu de la vie alors une
machine de turing c'est une sorte
d'abstraction du concept d'ordinateur
ça veut dire que tout ce qu'on peut
calculer avec un ordinateur classique
on peut aussi le calcul et avec une
simulation du jeu de la vie on peut
concevoir des portes logiques faire des
opérations des calculs et à la fin
reproduire avec le jeu de la vie
n'importe quel programme qu'on aurait pu
faire tourner sur un ordinateur
et voici l'illustration la plus folle de
cette idée ce que vous voyez ici ce sont
des séries de petits planeurs qui se
déplace dans une sorte de structure
carrée qui les créent
et quand on la regarde de loin c'est
planeur qui remplissent le carré ça fait
un peu comme un pixel il gaz qui serait
noir
[Musique]
il en existe aussi une version sans les
planeurs qui du coup ressemble beaucoup
à une case blanche et on peut associer
plusieurs structures de ce genre pour
former un réseau de gaz géante blanche
ou noire et en mettant les bonne
interaction ces casses géante peuvent
évoluer selon les règles du jeu de la
visite à la gv ou la simulation était
trop compliqué c'est pas moi qui les
fais donc on a une configuration du jeu
de la vie capable de simuler un jeu de
la vie j'espère que la profondeur de ce
résultat vous fascine autant que moi
alors une question qu'on peut se poser
donc on a vu tout ça c'est pourquoi
utiliser ces deux règles et pas d'autres
et bien connue elle les a trouvés par
tâtonnements en essayant d'avoir des
règles qui soient à la fois suffisamment
simples qui évite l'explosion du nombre
de cellules mais qui permettent de
former des structures suffisamment
complexe il existe quelques variantes du
jeu de la vie avec des règles
différentes et qui produisent aussi des
résultats assez riche mais pour essayer
de comprendre ce qui se passe c'est une
chose qu'on peut faire c'est d'étudier
un système encore plus simple on
l'appelle les automates cellulaires
élémentaire
[Musique]
alors petit point de vocabulaire j'ai
pas voulu vous ennuyer dès le départ
avec des mots savants mais le jeu de la
vie fait partie de la classe que ce
qu'on appelle les automates cellulaires
il s'agit de tous les systèmes constitué
de structures élémentaires simple les
cellules et qui évolue de façon
discontinue dans le temps selon des
règles fixées d'avancé et déterministe
et pour essayer de faire un automate
cellulaire encore plus simple que le jeu
de la vie eh bien on peut essayer de
descendre d'une dimension et de ne plus
considérer une grille de cellules mais
simplement une ligne
si notre système est une simple ligne de
cases noir une blanche
eh bien il va falloir spécifier les
règles d'évolution en fonction des
couleurs des cellules et de leurs
voisines
par exemple voici une règle d'évolution
envisageable alors il ya huit cas
possibles à considérer suivant la
couleur de la cellule et de ses deux
voisines
par exemple cette règle nous dit que si
une cellule est blanche et que ses deux
voisines sont blanches à malleval rester
mais que dans tous les autres cas elle
devient noir au tour suivant où elle
reste noir
alors essayons de voir ce qui se passe
si on simule cet exemple en partant
d'une configuration de départ très
simple juste une case noire pour que
tout ça soit visuel je vais représenter
l'évolution dans le temps en empilant
les lignes voici donc l'instant initial
ensuite le suivant on a appliqué les
règles
celui d'après et ainsi de suite et si je
représente ça de loin de façon accélérée
et bien voilà ce que ça donne
maintenant faisons une petite
modification à la règle précédente petit
changement maintenant une cellule noir
isolé moeurs et voici une image de
l'évolution qu'on obtient et si je fais
une autre modification possible
eh bien j'ai une autre évolution pour
complètement spécifier une règle
d'évolution gély il ya huit cas à
considérer est donc comme à chaque fois
le résultat peut être blanc ou noir
vous pouvez vous convaincre qu'il n'ya
que deux puissent ensuite c'est à dire
256 règle d'évolution possible dans cet
automate cellulaire
du coup c'est assez facile de les
programmer tout est de regarder de façon
exhaustive ce qui se passe pour chacune
d'elles d'autant que certaines règles en
plus sont symétriques les unes des
autres dans les années 80 le physicien
stephen wolfram s'est mis à étudier de
façon systématique toutes ces règles est
alors donné une numérotation pour
pouvoir les distinguer la première règle
qu'on a vu c'est ce qu'il appelle la
règle 254
la seconde c'est la 250 et la troisième
qu'on a vus c'était la numéro 50
regardons maintenant une nouvelle règle
intéressante celle à 126 elle à nouveau
très simple une case blanche isoler le
reste une case noire entourée de deux
cases noires meurt comme la
surpopulation et dans tous les autres
cas la case devient ou reste noir et
voici l'évolution de cette règle à
partir d'une simple quasiment initial
vous reconnaissez peut-être cette figure
on l'appelle le triangle de sirkin ce
qui est c'est un exemple bien connu de
structure fractale
c'est marrant non on a des règles
élémentaires complètement locales et qui
permettent de créer une structure
globale comme si on en avait prévu les
plans d' avance voyons un autre exemple
c'est la règle numéro 30
et voici son évolution c'est bizarre non
d'un côté on semble avoir des structures
relativement régulière et de l'autre ça
semble totalement aléatoire on voit de
temps en temps des structures plus
grosse mais aucun motif qui se répètent
vraiment
stephen wolfram a pu montrer que cette
structure était chaotique dans un sens
mathématique bien défini et qu'on peut
même s'en servir comme générateur
aléatoire de nombres allez un dernier
exemple de règles mais celle qui a le
plus fasciné wolfram il s'agit de la
célèbre règle numéro 110 et elle ne
diffère de la règle 126,1 celle du
triangle de cirque winski que par un
seul changement que le voici
si on est unis son évolution alors on
s'aperçoit que d'un côté à droite la
sarre est complètement blanc par contre
à gauche un espace des drôles de choses
à première vue le motif a l'air régulier
partout mais quand on y regarde de plus
près on voit que des structures
apparaissent se propage disparaissent et
a comme des interactions entre ces
structures sur un fond qui lui restent
réguliers les structures qui se propage
se comporte un peu comme les planeurs du
jeu de la vie et on peut simuler aussi
loin qu'on veut cet automate cellulaire
ce comportement étrange demeure c'est
pas quelque chose de régulier ce n'est
pas non plus quelque chose de chaotique
c'est entre les deux c'est comme si on
venait de créer un petit monde dans
lequel des formes de vie artificielle se
développerait et interagir est une sorte
de mini jeux de la vie en 2002 le
mathématicien matthew cook a publié une
démonstration du caractère universel de
la règle 110 c'est à dire qu'on peut
s'en servir pour simuler une machine de
turing est donc n'importe quelle
fonction calculable par un ordinateur
classique comme le jeu de la vie mais
malgré cette démonstration comme pour le
jeu de la vie on peut pas dire qu'on
comprenne vraiment pourquoi la règle
numéro 110 fonctionne comme ça et pas
les autres
l'émergence de la complexité et de
l'universalité d'un système aussi simple
reste une question mystérieuse comme
quoi même les programmes informatiques
les plus élémentaires n'ont pas fini de
nous étonner
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo n'hésitez
pas à la partager si vous l'avez
apprécié oubliez pas
la clause dyk et tout ça si vous voulez
creuser le sujet comme toujours j'ai
écrit un billet de blog qui accompagne
la vidéo qui donne un peu plus de
détails
les actualités de la chaîne c'est sur
facebook et sur twitter et vous pouvez
bien sûr me soutenir surtout dit merci à
bientôt
[Musique]